my friends cnbc reports the devastating
news
reddit group wall street bets behind
massive gamestop and amc
run-ups goes private invitation required
cnbc doesn't like wall street bets
because cnbc is where all these
crony hedge fund types and wall street
types go on the tv
and essentially it can manipulate
markets
and trick poor people into losing a lot
of money they say
wall street bets reddit chat room where
retail investors marshal against short
sellers went private wednesday
you must be invited to visit this
community the page now states
the forum's members topped three million
as of wednesday
the community gathered an army of rookie
day traders who go after heavily shorted
stocks pushing share prices higher
and squeezing out short selling hedge
funds my favorite part in all this
everybody loves it everybody except the
crony establishment elites but here's
what it looks like
you go to reddit right now you have to
be invited to this community
i suppose that means there's about three
million people who are still able to
easily access this and see what's going
on but if you're
you know layman looking in from the
outside and you didn't sign up like me
you can't see what's going on so let me
show you something real quick i just
want to show you the game stop stock
it's after hours has had 347
and 51 cents my friends some regular old
people
are becoming millionaires off of this i
saw a post from someone they put like
their life savings into it i guess and
then they made like a million dollars
i'm not saying that's a good idea i
think it's hugely risky
and to be fair there are some of these
you know wall street types
who are definitely saying it's a it's a
big mistake these people are gonna get
hurt some people probably will
that's why don't take any advice from
anyone anyone here on this show anybody
saying anything is not advice because we
got no idea we're talking about we are
not stock experts in any capacity
uh and i think for to a certain degree a
lot of people on wall street bets aren't
either
however to be fair a lot of people who
go on tv and tell you what to buy are
probably lying too
yeah now here's here's where it gets
really crazy this is the big the big big
drop discord bans wall street bets for
hate speech
and that's it that's the lie that's the
trick
they've been talking about how they
censor everybody for their hate speech
because they say naughty things that
offend people but what happens
when you get a group of people a large
group of people thousands tens of
thousands millions
who are saying we found out a way to
take the money from the one percent and
bring it back to the people
oh my we've discovered hate speech we
better shut down their ability to
coordinate
this to me looks like a dirty game first
they tried
they they halted trading on this on the
stock market it was a circuit breaker so
that's when like trading goes too crazy
they stop it
but then we saw that some of these
platforms like td ameritrade restricted
trading
so that we know what they're doing
behind the scenes the people at wall
street bets even think
that there's a coordinated effort to
manipulate the market to try and save
these hedge funds because someone's got
to bail them out
they could end up being in debt 10
billion dollars mean
they're gone now i don't know what you
guys think to me
this reaps a reeks of phony censorship
accuse them of hate speech that way they
can try and at least pretend like they
have some moral high ground
but who's buying it yeah i mean what did
you think when you allowed silicon
valley to aggressively police
speech what did you think was going to
happen of course they're going to be
using it and abusing it to help out
their friends their family members the
people who serve them
the people who give them money in and
this is huge according to s3 partners
short sellers lost 14.3 billion dollars
just just on game stock
not even including all the other ones
gamestop sorry games
game game exactly and then other people
other people are
answering back saying no no no short
sellers didn't lose people
won and enriched themselves to the tune
of 14.3 billion dollars because all
the market i mean you know manipulators
all these hedge funds managers that
are absolutely hated by the left and the
right are finally getting a taste of
their own medicine and a lot of people
are realizing hey
it's only capitalism when it benefits
them and we saw a massive
massive pushback by cnbc freaking out
cnn
wrote an article how trumpism explains
the gamestop
stock surge are you kidding me i mean if
if cnn couldn't absolutely hate it when
wall street hedge funds managers don't
get their way from
don't get their pound of flesh from main
street this absolutely
exemplifies it it's absolutely sickening
when the little guy wins
cnn is always going to be backing the
big guy it's crazy trump
trump is um gone i saw a post with
someone they're like wow trump
disappeared real quick didn't he he's
out of the presidency and like
we don't see him we don't hear from him
so what does cnn do
well it's trumpism i i knew it we said
it was coming
they're really out of touch because it's
just like a bunch of kids well i don't
know they're all kids but like using
reddit forums that's not
has nothing to do with trump's been
around since before trump they did use
that tactic to get trump elected
he here's what is new though guys
and since covet
there's a lot of working-class people
stuck at home
their jobs have been shut down uh
if you're in the service industry res
you're not making near the money that
you used to make
many of the people have lost their jobs
and so
listen i don't want to cry broke here
because i'm i'm not broke
but i will say this about covid and what
has happened
is that i got heavily involved
with my td ameritrade account i have one
that my financial advisor runs
and then i have my own little one that
because of covert and i was at home more
i started paying a lot of attention to
and if there have been stories written
i think like 16 million people have
signed up for their own
personal accounts and so what i think is
going on here
they're calling a time out like wow we
got 16 million new traders there's some
people that read
it that have figured out they've
gathered up
people that have been put out of work
the working class
and they figured out how to make money
and we have to call a time
out and figure out how do we respond
to all of these new traders and and this
new economy that's going on in the stock
market
and so they're coming up with excuses
while they try to figure out how they
stop this disruption
that it's taking their money away bro
yes but but
just think about what hedge funds
represent the destruction of the little
man
and the small businessman the individual
restaurant owners the individual
stores and provi everything is walmart
everything
is amazon everything's this big global
chain
and i think these people and again i
don't have a full understanding of wall
street bets and what's been going on
but it just feels like the working class
fighting back
and the elites call in a timeout we got
to figure out well that's what happened
that's what the nasdaq ceo was
considering today
thinking about holding and stopping
trades to recalibrate
their positions to of course combat
people on reddit and now people on
reddit
are even you know pushing their
discussions making their groups private
which is absolutely crazy here but one
thing that you also brought up during
the whole coronavirus uh 2020 year
stock market speculators were the only
ones who made
record high profits while everyone else
was wiped out
people will realize this people
understand that this is not right
because when we look at hedge funds
managers the people on wall street
they don't provide any services they
don't provide any goods they literally
move around zeros on the computer and
make more money for themselves and
people are scratching their heads like
hey if they could do it we could do it
as well bro
it's fine if someone is like yo i got 10
000 shares at a dollar
oh it's two dollars i'll sell it i just
made a bunch of money it's another thing
when they start putting shorts on stock
where they're basically betting
someone's going to fail
while saying we're infusing money but
i'll tell you what the problem is
okay fine you want to short sell
something going to take that bet it's
risky i accept that too you want to make
a risky bet you know what i don't like
is when they short a stock then they get
their buddies to go on tv
and go oh it's going to be bad you
better sell now and then everyone panics
and the stock crumples
they start laughing because they
manipulate the game to make money
this is what they are reaping this is
what they get and and the best part
you were mentioning this with covet and
all that a lot of these people
young people a lot of these people
needed money real bad and it took
months for the for for the congress to
get these checks out to even negotiate
these things
and some people were desperate got those
and used what they could and did what
they did
but there are some people who had some
lying around we just got 600
stimulus checks got sent around now you
get a bunch of board people
sitting around with their robinhood
accounts td ameritrade
and then someone says hey you know those
fat cats who made billions of dollars
off our back while our economy collapsed
you want to stick it to the man and
they're like what am i gonna do you got
a couple hundred bucks i sure do
from my stimulus drop it in my favorite
thing about this is the establishment is
being hoisted by their own petard you
know my favorite they want
they want to pump out these billions of
dollars 1400
stimulus checks are coming and what do
you think is going to happen when a
bunch of these young people are like
screw it and they dump it all to target
these short it to short squeeze out
these hedge fund managers it's robin
hood dude
yes that's what robin hood did stole
from the rich and gave to the poor
and now we're seeing it again digitally
that's not not a coincidence if this
really is a simulation
dude yeah and of course yeah you're
talking about an
app that people are using people are
using cash app people are using
robinhood
i personally tweeted out my like uh my
cash app and people are like oh
you're you're set you're you're selling
uh what was it shovels during the gold
rush here and i see what you're doing
here
and i'm like yeah i mean it makes sense
now of course i'm i'm always very
skeptical of reddit because i know
reddit could be manipulated
i know the stock market is fully
manipulated so we should be cautious
here
uh and and another thing to kind of
really really consider here is
wait until wall street bets wait until
that community finds out about bitcoin
okay i mean there's also another huge
potential here of people saying well
we're going to invest where
things actually matter where they
actually make an impact and this is a
sign that a lot of people on the left
and right are seeing as this huge
merger point of people finally coming
together putting their political
differences aside and saying you know
what
everything's rigged let's play the
market just like they play it i
you know i hear what you're saying but
you know what i think is more likely to
happen is that the hedge funds are going
to panic and find bitcoin because
they're
these shorts are being attacked all
right so i'll try to explain it i may be
getting it wrong because i'm not a stock
person so you guys can super chat and
then we'll get to that
but the general idea my understanding of
a short is that
i'll put it this way like ian let me
borrow that share real quick i'll pay
you for it next week
i then sell it to luke for 10 bucks i'm
hoping that in a week it's worth a
dollar
so then i'm holding 10 bucks here's your
dollar for the stock you lent me right
i'll pay you back for it now
but what happens when i sell it for 10
bucks to luke and then a week later to
100 bucks and then you know ian comes to
me and says all right 100 bucks is due
but i only have 10 i don't got the stock
anymore so what they're doing is by
by everyone buying into these stocks the
value skyrockets
and then the crazy thing is these hedge
funds who short the stock
there's no bottom it's an a near
infinite potential loss
if the game stop stock goes to 5 000
which i'm not saying it will then for
every share that they sold at six bucks
they owe that five grand and they only
got six bucks
so they're looking at what do you say
look like 14 billion dollars lost
just on uh according to s3 uh partners
just in
uh game stock uh alone i am not
offering anyone advice advocating for or
encouraging anything but i will tell you
my opinion oh man i love it
i love it so much i got mixed feelings
because it
it's dangerous for people to coordinate
and and game the stock market like
but it totally goes on every day that's
what they do that's exactly what they do
yeah that's the name of the job listen
listen look at
who was it loffler and purdue were they
the ones oh they were the ones who
they bought they moved these stocks
around uh leffler they moved these
stocks around just before covert or
whatever and they got called out for it
and they said it was totally legit
and we weren't the ones who did it sure
wealthy individuals with connections
with access always know the right moves
to make
it's just convenient isn't it but also
let's just think about
the really wealthy people and the
connected people the globalists and
you know i'll get fried for using that
word maybe i don't know but
the global when they're shutting down
the economy sending everyone home put
mask on you can't work
they see the stock market crash and the
globalists have all the money to invest
in the stock market as it crashes and
they've benefited
and everybody knows it if you've got a
brand you've been following
the rich made a ton of money
during colvin i'm embarrassed and i'm
not
i'm not super rich but i'm embarrassed
by how much money i've made during
covet by buying devalued stock and then
sitting back for the last six months and
watching it grow it's embarrassing how
much money i've made
sitting on my rear end at home
it is a transfer of wealth from the
working class to the rich
and when i hear about millions of
regular people saying i got a stimulus
check let's let's let's do it
you know what that is we had a bunch of
people storm the capital that was dumb
they accomplished nothing they're going
to charge people sedition nothing's
accomplished from it the state
now the feds are like we want more
security powers nothing gets
accomplished
i'll tell you what really scares them
when you go after their pocketbook when
the regular working people
figured out a way to stick it to the man
and so they they panicked so hard
it's hate speech they're bigots
economics is our only solution yeah
again
no seriously we can't count on the
ballot
anymore we can't vote them out but if we
can make them pay an economic
price for the exploitation of the
working class
then you have a shot yeah i'm loving the
left and the right together on this one
i'm seeing like like leftists you got
kyle kalinski you got vosh they're all
like this is fantastic you got right
wing individuals cheering for it and i'm
sitting back like yes unity
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you